[Music]  in the car  we're all going no you I said we're all  going  you do not seem to do that cousin  survival 64  [Applause]  [Applause]  you're no war okay  allow me to reintroduce myself my name  is home  there's two of them a two billion  dollars worth of us if the three of us  don't work together billions of people  will die your sister is one of the  toughest baddest most capable women I've  ever encountered know what kind of girl  I see what you do you think I'm stupid  of course I think you're stupid  [Music]  wings on  [Music]  we're gonna need cars and guns  oh I can handle that plan I'm sorry to  bring this here mama Luke this is your  home  go away cool you're gonna get one style  - whoopee I'm Superman there comes a  crafter that vampire never gives up  in a fire oh no this is not good we're  going for a ride  movie directors on my island mother  allow me to reintroduce myself my name  is  [Music]  [Music]